[MUSIC]
He's mercilessly despairing me.
If I climb east, I should be able to get everything.
It's terrible,
shut up
already!
It's something to see what happens from now on Well, there's no new
ones there You know, you didn't get selected Wow, the prefecture is Airley That's the extent of the divine water I'm
tired of the ugliness that seeps from such a weak house, isn't it?  No
matter what they say,
I really want to see the stars If you get along well, you should
get on the catcher  So
please do anything, I'll give it
back
[music
] Let's put aside your bottom-oriented stupidity, let's distinguish the head and let's go to the center,
especially
if you can bring down the curtain of his life, climb your head  I'll
let you finish Mr. Yoru's story with your own hands
Uh,
are you really surprised that
Yoru-san's been doing this because I don't need him anymore
?